yeah you see that with some people when
they smoke pot like
like like my mom's like that she's a
[ __ ] whipper snapper and she smokes
pot and it's just like
and she hates it because she's not in
control anymore right you know
you see that sometimes but i i like that
i like the things that are like
humbling me and making my ego go down
the mushroom is pretty hardcore but
the mushrooms i've always been afraid i
haven't done it yet but all my friends
take them and i've always been afraid
because i've always been like a super
lightweight with weed
yeah like all my friends will eat the
same size like like even my wife will
eat like the
eat these edibles and i can only eat
like a quarter of it yeah and it hits me
harder than the big than the full one
hits her yeah
yeah so i'm just like a super
lightweight so i'm afraid
i'm afraid to take mushrooms yeah i was
too a micro dose or something
i literally had to have somebody catch
me off guard with them the way we ended
up even taking them was
um we had them in our freezer after
tribeca film festival we had a meeting
with some amazon executives
and we're out and at a bar and they see
we're not drinking they're like you guys
are potheads aren't you we're like
yeah yeah we don't really drink and uh
they're like let's go smoke pot at your
house so we go back with these
it's two amazon executives we didn't
even know them we didn't even know their
names like we're just like
hanging out at our apartment smoking pot
and i'm talking to one of them this
woman's just like
saying how um she she she takes
mushrooms with seth rogen all the time
and like seth rogen loves american
juggalo
you should take mushroom successful i'm
like i've never taken much time i i'm
too scared whatever
i'm like we have him but we're scared
and she's like you have mushrooms i'm
like yeah
she's like let's do them right now so
we're like [ __ ] it all right let's do it
and we did our first mushroom trip and
it was scary
it was very uncomfortable and uh i
haven't eaten meat since
my all my relationships are better we
meditate every day twice a day
you know uh we have a spiritual life you
know that word scares you full-blown
hippies basically
yeah because i grew up a punker like i
was
into like crust punk like i was just
like the furthest thing i made fun of
hippies i made fun of the grateful dead
and
like we're so typical we started taking
this stuff and like grew my hair out
wearing tie-dye we're the biggest
deadheads you can imagine now
so uh i i think it it caught me off
guard it caught my ego off guard like i
didn't have time to be too scared about
them or anything it was just like oh
you're all of a sudden taking these
things i was your age
[ __ ] changed me changed me and i was
like oh thank god man i was running out
of
my ego was kind of backed into a corner
my ways of dealing with the world i was
like
my tools weren't as sharp you know like
i was like i need to bring
a in retrospect it's easy to say this
but i needed
a sense of connectedness to come back
over my being to keep even making these
films
so uh yeah the mushrooms coming into my
life that which
then led to acid which led to dmt which
led to toad which led to ayahuasca
diamane medicine all kinds of [ __ ] and
um just just coming at you just coming
at your ego from different angles like
just trying to keep it humble just yeah
yeah yeah it's good i think it's a good
practice for anyone how often do you do
it do you like micro
i know a lot of people are doing it
every day all day like at work
a little bit like a micro dose we don't
really work so there's no like this
when we trip we [ __ ] trip and i just
go off you go oh yeah and i think more
people should do that
there's a lot of talk of micro doses
these days but what we always end up
saying is like
the main problem is people not taking
enough like we see people they'll take
one tab of acid and then struggle with
their ego the whole time it's like why
don't you take
three and just [ __ ] be god for a
little bit
you know like just do it do the [ __ ]
thing be god that's what he's doing is
stripping away the layers
of that of you that make you think
you're you
and it's actually [ __ ] a huge relief
you feel incredible in the days and
months after psychedelics
so really oh oh my god but especially
mushrooms it like
if you had any sense of anxiety
depression whatever just the clouds just
part i mean there's studies now that say
like pretty much six months of relief
following a mushroom journey talk about
yours that time
you casted a heroic dose of mushrooms
which is five grams
heroic yeah five grams wow it sounds
like a lot yeah it deserves that name i
would say oh yeah totally i all i can
say is like
i was having panic attacks i don't have
panic attacks anymore
you know it's like it really did kind of
shift something within me
from the inside out where i'm like oh
it's all good like nothing i'm worrying
about is worth like
having a panic attack about yeah it can
be pretty simple
messages but you have to like feel them
you know you did
five [ __ ] grams by herself like
that's another part of the heroic dose
you have any people with you you're just
alone yeah i was desperate i was like
like
sean's saying like up against a wall
like freaking out not understanding
what's going on in my life like wanting
to get a grip and
of course like my hero's terence mckenna
so i'm going to listen to him you know
and i'm glad i did
do you remember everything pretty
vividly
uh it's so ineffable it's funny because
i was out in l.a
we're we are never more than this far
apart from each other
and i was going on adam carolla's
podcast in l.a so i was like i'm just
gonna go do this
i'll be back in a day and i go out there
and i'm hanging out with isaac out in
l.a
who shot florida man and cam girls yeah
and cass is calling us like every half
hour like
what the [ __ ] is going on you're not
real
you're not real and i'm like yeah i am
i'll be home tomorrow i didn't even
understand the extent to which she was
[ __ ] tripping balls like she was
having what are they called like tactile
tactile uh hallucinations where you're
like your phone felt like a spiky ball
like
that's a level of tripping that's like
[ __ ]
yeah i was his mom i was jumping
timelines i was like
greeted by like um i mean i got the like
angelic message like
it's okay like everything's okay but
then you know my mind's trying to make
sense and i get into this like paranoid
loop of like
no it's not okay you're actually like
yeah
like maniacal fear come over me but you
know so
in some ways i had one of the worst
trips i've ever had and so it's
interesting to say like oh i had this
horrible trip like i was scared i was
calling shawn i was
all this like fear and
paranoia existential dread existential
dread but the truth is it lasts like six
hours
and then you can like feel and integrate
all that fear
and take that with you and be like oh
like i'm okay
you know that was a feeling i went
through but i'm really okay
and it's actually life isn't what i
think it is so let me have fun with life
and it's kind of
has allowed me psychedelics allowed me
to be a little more playful with my
existence because i really did get from
that message like
oh sean's not real and then i was like
oh well
love is real enough for me you know so
this might not be real this might be an
illusion this might be
all my sensory perception playing tricks
on me and i might not actually
be where i think i am doing what i think
i'm doing but there is something about
this experience that is worth
holding on to and it's like go simple
foundational stuff of like love
you know it's like so corny but it's so
true yeah i mean
like the first time i smoked dmt it was
so
mind-blowing and and like holy [ __ ] what
are these colors what are these fractals
where am i right now but the eeriest
feeling of familiarity where you're like
i've been here before i this seems
freaky but like is this where i was
before i was born like or
is this where i'm going when i die and
like that's what i've deduced
from a lot of this stuff we're not the
type of people who take a lot of
psychedelics and pretend to know
anything
additional i just feel more comfortable
in my being and more comfortable knowing
like
this is temporary there's no way to kill
or crush consciousness it just keeps
going
the cycle keeps going and uh yes
like it it invited in that connectedness
that i think i needed to keep making
films
and making podcasts and uh now now like
i just feel like we're building
community now and like we're not
filmmakers we're not podcasters those
are things we do
we're not even community builders we're
just we're just hanging out we're doing
our thing i'm not looking to wear any
masks or identities or labels i'm not
like i've had all the validation i could
possibly need for filmmaking and
and all this [ __ ] so i'm like really
determined to find out what life's all
about
i see the movie interstellar yeah of
course like how you said talked about
like love
it like it's its own it like transcends
time and gravity and that movie the love
is the
i went into the bookshelf
crazy that you brought that up because
literally that's the only reference that
she ever says about that trip is she's
like it felt like i was
behind the bookshelf in interstellar
that's what i was thinking picturing
when she was saying that
yeah that's yeah that's a heavy one i
mean an ayahuasca will take you right
there and keep you there for six hours
like it one-way ticket to the shadow
realm and it's like am i gonna make
friends with my demons
and realize they're not that big of a
deal or am i gonna fight them and you
know
it's all fear of death stuff that starts
coming up and if like
these things teach you how to not be
scared of death so you can live
and that's what we probably trip like
once a month yeah
i mean life is pretty simple when you
think of it as like breath play
you know like yeah really just when you
can bring it to the breath and like
everything else is like i'm playing a
game of having running these thoughts
but when you realize like what it's all
about
is like following your breath and like
connecting to that
inner peace the connection you kind of
have a good time even when you're having
a bad time because you're like oh i'm so
stressed but you can kind of
have an outsider perspective on it you
know so you're not so much as in the
stress or in the fear in the paranoia
you're like oh look at me
being stressed doesn't mean i'm not
going to look stressed to sean but it's
like
i have more of a sense of humor about it
yeah you take it like life less
seriously
yeah it's like we're actors in a movie
i'm not gonna [ __ ] try to [ __ ]
method act this thing and
take it too seriously like it it just
gives you that
that one step removed where you're like
oh okay cool this isn't that big of a
[ __ ] deal